thank you Yasser yes we are indeed with
the executive director of the grand
Chester and one of the masterminds
behind the grandchester Michael
kodarkowski Michael first of all welcome
to the show welcome back to the studio
from inside the organization how did
this tournament look for you well as
always uh tournament from inside looks
different than from outside but I do
believe that it went very well uh last
round it's exciting we're definitely
going to have clear winner no matter
what and the field is very strong
probably the strongest field in
Bucharest at least and one of the
strongest the grandchild store speak
about that because we had a lot of
Fighting Chess in this tournament as
well almost 30 percent of the games were
decisive how did you enjoy this Fighting
Chance between these great players well
first of all classical cheers is not
that right it's not that yeah so that's
number one and number two uh these guys
you know want to fight
regardless of the color of pieces and
and we saw this so there are even some
draws were very well played and they
were very exciting yeah uh speaking
about the grandchester and the upcoming
events uh I believe you have some news
breaking news for us uh to share well uh
we have actually uh no breaking breaking
news uh we are going to Warsaw tomorrow
everyone will be flying or somebody who
will join us there will come a little
bit later uh world champion Dean
clearing
after he won World Championship match he
uh contacted and asked if we can uh I
love him of the torment in Warsaw so he
was eager to come to book areas he even
announced a couple of times during press
conferences during his world
championship match regardless of the
outcome
but he asked that he needs here he feels
some fatigue and
wants to recuperate but he will continue
afterwards so we replace him with
American Grandmaster livon aronen that's
not a bad replacement at all yeah not at
all not at all such an exciting player
we have Levon aronian coming but we also
have one Magnus Carlson coming and
joining us I just wanted to say that you
know he don't underestimate the number
one in the world Magnus Carlson who will
be playing in Versa and Zagreb yes and
we were looking forward to seeing the
former world champion and the new world
champion we will not see them in Warsaw
but we will see them in Zagreb is that
correct uh I'm not sure about that we
might not see see them playing against
each other but they are both on the tour
absolutely absolutely Michael thank you
very much for joining us exciting news
and we'll be seeing you in a couple of
days in Warsaw yes and maybe I only have
some breaking news from Warsaw too
looking forward to that guys back to you
in the studio thank you for that yes
dingler and